It fell off! It doesn't count!
19. 19. 19.
She was 100% on JD.
Ricky, it fell off! She had 1 in 3.
Ricky!
1 in 4 is 19.
The bullseye is 20.
Oh, okay.
That was not what was advertised earlier, I feel like.
The bullseye is harder to hit than JD Van's head.
You hit the bullseye, it's 20.
Ricky, she had 15, 1 in 4.
On the board, and 3.
1.
19.
Thank you.
I was like, dude, I'm not worried about this.
I heard you were worried about this.
I thought JD was 10.
I got excited, you know.
It can be 15.
What?
So between the first two people on our team, we got that.
That shot right there would be so sick.
Oh my god.
Yeah, Bowen could never.
All right, keep them.
All right.
Keep them alive.
Good job.
Yes, yes.
Can't just be that good at something, man.
It's not cool.
Give it all the event.
Yeah.
All right.
We'll take one.
Oh!
Oh, he does it.
I did it.
That's like a rat tap.
Rats doing that.
Dude.
That's good for safety.
That's enough.
I'm done.
Thank you.
All right.
Sure.
Thank you.